cliff kingsbury cardinals headquarters
spoke to reporters via conference call
on
tuesday and addressed among other things
the development of kyler murray and he
said this regarding murray's second
season
we'd love to have kyler back for the
on-field offseason program do i think
it's going to stunt his growth i don't
think so i think he's figured out what
he has to do and i expect him to take a
big step and of course that's in
reference to the reality that there will
likely be no on-field off-season program
for any team which will be a problem for
younger players who need those reps in
the off season to reach their full
potential and we were with kingsbury at
the scouting combine chris and it was
clear that kingsbury believes that
murray is on the brink of becoming a
superstar i compare him to patrick
holmes in 2018 lamar jackson in 2019 it
could be kyler murray in 2020 second
season explodes as one of the best
quarterbacks in the nfl but it's going
to be harder to do that without the
opportunity to continue to work and work
and understand and grow and develop in
the offseason i know it's something
that's going to affect all teams equally
but it's going to affect the younger
quarterbacks more than it's going to
affect the older ones who don't need the
off-season program yeah i mean there's
no doubt about that now the good thing
is you know for a kyler murray
it's the same coaching staff as last
year and it's the same offense he's run
all through college so at least there's
not more learning to do there yes is he
gonna miss out on lack of maybe more
knowledge of defenses and let's deep
dive into certain disguises and things
that teams did to us last year yes he's
gonna miss out on that uh but but
nonetheless i don't look at that and go
oh man that's a season breaker for kyler
murray no you know hey hopefully that
this cobin 19 the restrictions can
loosen up at some point where he'll be
able to go out and throw passes with
deandre hopkins and other receivers on
his team to just at least work on
throwing timing rhythm all of those type
of things but ultimately mike i mean my
thoughts are like you and i know i mean
when we ask cliff kingsberry and even
when i talk to him about kyler murray
off camera his face lights up i mean
this is a guy that i think you know
cliff kingsbury had his eye on for a
long long time
as a freaky freaky athlete and player
altogether and i'm with you man i think
he's gonna explode onto the scene this
year i do with them improving their
offense a little bit the kenyan drake
edition and now of course with dee
hopkins there mike that is going to uh
bring his game to an another level or
another stratosphere the one a morgan
would be more concerned about just along
those lines would be like a daniel jones
who is total regime change right and now
you got a new offensive coordinator a
new head coach i think life will be
harder on him as far as when he jumps
back into training camp more than a kyle
or murray will here in the 2020 season
well the challenge for the coaching
staff will be to come up with the best
possible transition from what they did
last year understanding what they did
last year what tyler jones knows and
maybe incorporate concepts slowly not
just put him in a position where he's
got to pick up a brand new offense right
out of the gates as everybody is still
trying to deal with this upside down
calendar the nfl is going to have um
where do we want to see improvement from
kyler murray unlike mahomes who played
one game as a rookie and lamar jackson
who played maybe half the season we saw
kyler murray wired a wire and we saw
greatness we saw offensive rookie of the
year where does he need to take that
next step
well mike i i don't look at like any
part of his game and go man
he leaves the pocket too early or man
he's not very good in the pocket he
can't over you know i don't see any
glaring weaknesses as far as just he
needs plen to play and more support
around him in general but i mean as far
as playing the position
the kid's a natural he's pure i mean
it's like patrick mahomes where yeah you
go sometimes ooh i wish he would step
into that throw a little bit better and
not just rely on his great talent you
know other than that though mike i just
don't see anything where i go oh man if
he doesn't correct this this could be
some crazy year he's got great mechanics
great feel in the pocket he looks to
throw the ball first when he does throw
it he's got a special arm he can throw
it a lot of different ways you know
throws it on the run so you know i don't
have one an answer for you there to say
oh he's really got to work on this no i
just think he's got to play and they got
to do more to open up their offense and
expand that and and just help him with
support around him
yeah i mean it's just the game slowing
down a little bit more and a little bit
more and getting kylo murray to the
point where before the play he knows
what the defense is going to be doing
here has a better idea of it because at
that point he can use his physical gifts
even more effectively if he doesn't have
to process right in those first few
frenetic seconds of a play what's really
going on once his brain begins to become
that super computer that has seen all of
the permutations and all of the options
and all the movement pre-snap and and
knows what's coming and he can impose
his will physically when he knows or has
reason to know what the defense is doing
that's when he is going to be an
incredible talent he already is an
incredible talent he isn't paying
attention to it because they didn't win
enough games they weren't in prime time
we didn't get to see it live i remember
watching in the preseason first throw i
saw him make the ball explodes off of
his hand the ball explodes into the
hands of the receiver it's this tiny
little guy that's not supposed to be
generating that kind of power that kind
of velocity that kind of violence with a
football and he does it he's going to be
a special player for years to come and i
don't think that that this this absence
of an offseason program is going to
affect him the way it could affect
others
yeah i i agree i mean you know we kind
of stated all the all the reasons why
and one this is a guy that's very mature
i mean just you know in in our little
crossover with him two years at the
super bowl
you know having to meet him there and
then just everything you see the way he
handles himself in front of the podium
the way he handles himself on the
football field and the way he plays the
position it's very mature it really is
that's where i was blown away by him and
daniel jones last year you know daniel
jones the same thing you know they do a
lot of the little nuance things that a
quarterback does that you don't see
until maybe year three or four
and they already got that part down and
that's where i'm excited about kyla
murray i mean yeah i think he's a
superstar in the waiting and i think he
will explode onto the scene this year
more in the national scene in national
media
and i do have to say this on the way to
break i thank cliff kingsbury for
bringing back a phrase that i first
heard in the 70s about stunting your
growth that used to be the argument
against cigarettes chris not that it'll
give you cancer but if you're a kid and
you're smoking it will stunt your growth
i don't know if there was any evidence
of that whatsoever but that was what
they used to get kids to not smoke in
the 70s
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports